je me dirige en ce moment vers fulford à
bosser sur une petite île proche de la
grande île de vancouver est ici dans le
village et à 1600 électeurs qui ont voté
à plus de 80 % pour le parti vert à la
dernière élection fédérale
alors je vais essayer de comprendre
pourquoi les verts sont si populaires
dans la région
[Musique]
j'ai ramassé nova sur la route là qui
s'appelait du bateau en même temps que
moi moi il pleut tellement qu'on va
aller à l'intérieur parce que cette île
elle est sur la circonscription
d'elizabeth may la chef du parti vert
elle est élue depuis 2011 avec de très
fortes majorités et les verts ont
maintenant un autre député sur l'île de
vancouver et au total il pense être
capable de rafler tous les comtés de
l'île de vancouver et des alentours donc
on compte six circonscriptions
c'est en fait l'endroit où ils peuvent
le plus facilement marquer des points
dans cette élection
bon ici on est dans une bergerie fin
marchand de fromages laurent va voir un
peu si on peut parler à des gens
vraiment libéral
résout pas tout le monde qui veut
[Musique]
on retrouve vraiment des choses à vendre
sur le bord de la route partout il n'y a
jamais de vendeurs ici c'est des fleurs
de l'autre côté de la route c d e donc
eu confiance en fait on fait confiance
aux clients qui laisse ton argent dans
la boîte
lille revendique le titre d' endroit en
amérique du nord où il ya le plus de
véhicules électriques par habitant on en
compte 22 pour 1000 personnes alors que
le reste du canada c3 ici c'est une
communauté d'une trentaine de personnes
surtout des jeunes qui vivent au même
endroit qui partagent tous on voit
qu'ils sont ils ont des panneaux
solaires il faut pousser près de 70% des
ce qu'ils mangent qu'ils sont presque
autosuffisant et on peut voir que ça
s'appelle aloi
[Musique]
c'est un camping primitif c'est parce
qu'on enseigne aux gens comment à vivre
en harmonie avec la nature
et puis donc là il ya des objets qu'on
fabrique à partir des éléments de la
nature
marquer des paniers en fait en train de
régénérer tout le village pour que
justement les enfants puissent se
développer à pleine maturité c'est notre
gros projets culturels
donc ça passe par la connexion à la
nature comme comme fondation
on le sent quand même on la sent quand
même la culture hippie oui c'est
toujours présent causé beaucoup de gens
déménagent ici avec l'intention de
changer leur vie rate également
il quitte la ville il quitte les lieux
qu'ils ont pas nourri et cherche je
cherche une nourrice mende aucun gros
focus sur la guérison ce les façons de
vivre
alternativement pour créer plus de paie
quoi il ya un piano public juste devant
l'océan la difficile à battre comme
emplacement
[Musique]